- [Mark] All right, Ice.
- [Ice] Let's get it.
- [Mark] Ice, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Ice] South Central California.
- [Mark] So, Central L.A.?
And you grew up with both your parents?
- [Ice] Not necessarily.
It was a little tricky.
Adopted.
I had adoptive parents.
Both my parents was on crack.
Both my-
- [Mark] Your real parents were?
- Both my real parents were users, yes.
- [Mark] So, how was your life
with the adoptive family?
- Shaky as hell.
It wasn't something that was pleasant,
but it wasn't something that was just
all the way down the drain
if you understand what
I'm saying, you feel me?
But, for the most part,
it was shaky as hell.
I didn't get to spend much time with them.
My mom always at work.
Night shift.
Working as a nurse, as
an LVN at St. Francis,
always gone at nighttime,
sleep during the daytime
when I come home,
from whatever I'm doing,
running the streets,
blase, blase, blah, school,
whatever the case may be.
Pops was a rolling stone.
He was already out the
house, in and out the house.
Adoptive parents was Jamaican.
So I had a little taste
of a different culture,
but at the same time, we live in L.A.,
so it's a whole bunch of
different ethnicities.
You got Jamaicans, Belizians,
a lot of everybody.
- [Mark] What kind of kid
were you in high school?
- High school?
- [Mark] Did you go to high school?
- Somewhat (laughs).
- [Mark] When did the
gang life start for you?
- Gang life started 11, started
being gang affiliated at 11.
- [Mark] 11.
- That's when I really
started getting into trouble,
fucking up shit, jumping into houses.
Stealing cars, including my mama car
when I got the chance.
Yeah, I was just a bad ass little kid.
I was mischievous and running around,
between me getting kicked out
and running away, just because I wanted
to be a part of the streets.
It's (chuckles).
- [Mark] So you went to YA at some point?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] YA is the Youth Authority.
- [Mark] That's like basically
prison for kids, right?
- Mm-hmm.
Prison for kids.
Came home, 24, I'm 26 now.
- [Mark] And then when
you went out on your own,
where'd you go?
- Shit, I was actually homeless.
- [Mark] You were homeless.
- I was homeless for a while.
When I got out, I was homeless,
running the streets still.
Jobs wasn't fucking with me.
I'm a felon, of course.
So, I just got to get it out the mud,
do whatever I gotta do,
sell this, sell that,
rob this, rob that.
Get it however I can.
But, it's like...
We had this conversation.
So, you know, it's like
living in this environment,
we're forced to go out
and go get it, you know?
It's not something that's
just provided for us
like everybody else.
- [Mark] Yeah, you didn't
have, you didn't grow up-
- Silver spoon quote unquote.
- [Mark] You didn't
grow up in Beverly Hills
with a dad who's a doctor
and a mom who's a...
- You know, I'm 16 with a
Tesla and iPhone, iPhone 11.
Shit, I didn't see a motherfucking what?
I seen the chirp at 12 and that was it.
- [Mark] Yeah, the
opportunities that you had.
- Limited.
- [Mark] Limit you and what possibilities
are out there for you, right?
- Limited. Look at me. I'm a tall dude.
I could've been somewhere
playing basketball or football.
I'm good at both, but, you know,
I never figured out where I woulda went.
- [Mark] Did you have
any role models as a kid
that might've, you could
have emulated and followed?
- All the role models around us
was either on the block or in jail
and we couldn't talk to the role models,
so it's like...
And then the people that were
the actual quote unquote
figure role models
that we should look up to,
we was too much of
knuckleheads or hoodlums
or whatever the case may be for them
to even sit down and have
the patience with us.
Like, look, this how
you need to do things.
And shit, probably as kids,
we was probably looking
at them too, like, shit,
I ain't tryna follow you.
Like you doing the good shit.
I wanna have fun.
And that's how shit go.
It's just like the path
is real, real different.
We all different.
- [Mark] As a Crypt,
you're a Crypt, right?
- Yeah.
Have you lost friends?
- More.
Friends ain't even the word, man.
Lost brothers, comrade, family.
It's not just, this ain't no friendship,
this ain't just no brotherhood.
It's a brotherhood, but
it's more than that,
it's way more than that.
- [Mark] Becomes your family, right?
- It becomes your family.
You become tied in with everybody.
You done been homeless with everybody.
You don't been, you in the hood,
you thugging it with everybody.
Hey, let me crash at your spot.
Nah, you can't crash on my spot,
but I got a little something for you here.
Damn, thank you, bro.
Like I really needed this, bop.
Oh, what's the deal, bro?
Blase, blase, blase, blah,
we get into this together.
Oh, we gonna chop it up, like man,
everybody done been through a
whole bunch of shit together
and it's like once them
niggas is gone, they gone.
And a lot of people don't realize that.
As far as the gang banging
goes, do I regret it? No.
Would I change it? No.
But would I tell the next
motherfucker to do it?
No.
'Cause it's...
It's a loopholes now, man.
Like I'm even going
through some shit right now
where I can't really even
go into details like that
where it'll be over bound,
but it's, you know, gun
play gets you caught up.
And I'm going through
some shit right now, so.
- [Mark] You're facing a murder charge?
- Something along those lines.
And, man, shit ain't easy, bruh.
- [Mark] That'll change your life.
- Forever.
- [Mark] Forever.
- Either you could be
behind the four walls
with a whole bunch of niggas
taking showers together
or you could be outside
living life and getting money
with fucking bitches,
doing what you need to do,
building your empire, you feel me?
'Cause a lot of people, man,
fuck all the bullshit,
focus on y'all selves,
'cause cameras everywhere,
snitches everywhere, everybody talk,
niggas don't mind they business.
- [Mark] The laws are harsher.
- The laws are harsher,
especially California laws,
especially California laws.
Niggas don't got no self-defense laws.
It makes shit harder for us.
As the years have gone by,
it wasn't like this, what,
even nine years ago, it
wasn't nothing like this.
Nine, eight, you can even
go back six years ago,
it wasn't really like
this, but all our fuck ups.
In all honesty, that's what it is,
all our fuck ups, cuz, got the white man
back on us tough.
(siren blaring)
But they don't realize that
they put us in this situation.
We've been put in this
situation by the white man
to dig ourselves out.
- [Mark] You think a lack of opportunity,
lack of hope that you guys had growing up,
the broken families, all that stuff?
- [Ice] As far as like-
- [Mark] Did it set you up for failure?
- [Ice] I wouldn't say that.
In a sense, yeah, been set up for failure
because at the end of the day,
who put them crakes there,
who put them train cars down here in L.A.
with all the guns and drugs?
Who really put all that here?
Now you got a situation like
myself, cracked out parents.
Now I'm missing on the extra relationship
that I could have had.
And I just met them
recently, just recently.
And as far as recently,
I'm saying this year.
- [Mark] Where are they now?
- [Ice] Englewood.
- [Mark] They're living
in a house, apartment?
- [Ice] House in Englewood.
- [Mark] What did your
biological parents say to you?
- More so just my mom.
But they actually been clean for a while.
And that was a surprise,
a blessing, you know?
Me being, dealing with a
whole bunch of anger issues
and mental issues, as well,
I was diagnosed with schizophrenia.
Me not knowing that as a kid, you feel me,
and bipolar disorder, me
not knowing that as a kid,
I'd snap on everything
and I had anger issues.
Elementary school, I threw a stapler
at a kid head.
I got suspended for throwing
a stapler at a kid head.
I was only in third grade.
I got kicked out elementary school,
Century Park Elementary.
And it's like, all that
shit leads up to shit, man.
Your environment is the biggest factor
in how you live your life.
- [Mark] You think environment's
more powerful than family?
- Environment plays a
bigger factor than family.
- Because my family
could be going to church,
doing everything that, you
feel me, is the right thing,
but I could be going to
school at the same time,
but I'm living in the hood neighborhood
and everybody in that
school is big, you feel me,
and then now I'm attracted to that.
Now it's like all right,
just test stuff is boring,
I'm gonna go have fun.
So your environment's
gonna always overpower it.
Think of a kid at Disneyland.
They go to the food court, they tripping.
They don't really want no food.
They wanna be over here at the rides.
You know, environment is everything.
You could be with your
family over here eating food.
Nah, I'm cool, come
on, let's go over here.
I wanna get on Superman or
whatever the case may be.
Shit's different.
Our lives ain't the same.
That's why I don't live by the rules.
As much as I want to, I see
that's not gonna get me nowhere.
But it's how you play it.
- [Mark] Are you scared
now for your future?
- I'm a always be straight,
but as far as opportunities
and future opportunities,
I'll probably be missing out some.
I'll probably be missing out on a lot.
- [Mark] If you have an
extended prison time.
- Football numbers.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Football numbers, man.
Probably the lower
football numbers, but yeah,
it's not looking too good.
I'm trying to,
I'm trying to juggle a
lifestyle getting money
and doing all this,
it'll have you playing
with guns, too, man.
- [Mark] Fast money ends
up getting you either
long prison time or death, right?
- It's one of the other, one or the other.
Or, man, that's it.
Ain't no other way around it.
The judge ain't playing with nobody.
DAs, what?
You think just 'cause
you got a paid lawyer
that they on your side?
Them niggas is friends.
This lawyer, this judge,
they working on the same team,
so you just wasted however
much money you just used
to put in this case.
I ain't with that.
- [Mark] Do you feel like
you get stereotyped as,
because you're a young black man
you're gonna be assumed
guilty even from the start,
even by your lawyer?
- I just hope not.
You know.
They say Crypts don't got
no religion or nothing.
No, a nigga believe in God.
I believe God got a nigga.
I believe God got me in his
best interest, in his favor.
You feel me, so.
Shit gonna be all right.
No matter what the outcome is actually,
'cause at the end of the
day, I know what I did
and one other person know what I did
and whatever happen can't be taken back.
So...
Stay in school and don't do drugs kids.
- [Mark] All right, Ice.
Thank you so much for talking with me.
- No problem, man.
- [Mark] And good luck with
whatever happens with your case.
- Likewise.